we know that Forex in the open interval
from negative 1/2 to 1/2 that negative 2
over 1 minus 2x is equal to this series
and they say using this fact find the
function that corresponds to the
following series and like always pause
this video and see if you can work
through it alright so the first thing
you might say is well how do we know
that this expression is equal to this
series and you might recognize this
series as a geometric series where the
first term is negative 2 and then the
common ratio to get each successive term
we're multiplying we're multiplying by
2x we're multiplying by 2x and so for a
geometric series like this the sum is
going to be the first term negative 2
over 1 minus the common ratio which is
exactly what we have over there so
that's why we know that and this right
over here this gives us our radius of
convergence the X values for which this
thing will actually converge but now
let's now that we feel good about this
first statement let's try to answer
their actual question so we want to find
the function that corresponds to the
following series so my instinct to say
well how does this series relate to the
series they gave us let's see this first
term is a negative 2 this first term is
a negative 2x this is a negative 4x this
is a negative 2x squared so the thing
that might jump out at you is that this
the second the second series they gave
us is the is the antiderivative of this
first one or we could say this first
series is a derivative of the second one
what's the derivative of negative 2x
with respect to X well it's a negative 2
what's the derivative of negative 2x
squared with respect to X well it's
negative 4x and so on and so forth and
so if we were to call this let me call
let me call this thing right over here
actually let me just say that this is
equal to G of X well the way I can take
this right-hand side and get G of X is
by taking the antiderivative taking the
indefinite integral and so what we can
do we can take the indefinite integral
of both sides DX so DX on the right hand
side I'm going to get G of X
and on the left-hand side I am going to
get actually let me write it this way on
the so on the left-hand side I'll just
rewrite it I'm gonna get the indefinite
integral of all right it is negative 2
DX over 1 minus 2x and that's just
another way of writing what I have on
the left-hand side here this is equal to
G of X right if I take the
antiderivative of this or an
antiderivative this is this G of X or
the constant would have been 0 so I'll
say is equal to G of X and so the key
here is well what's the indefinite
integral of this stuff and you might
immediately recognize well this what I
have here in the bottom I have its
derivative here on the top if I consider
this to be you if I say U is equal to 1
minus 2 X this is just u substitution
then D u is equal to the derivative of
this with respect to X which is negative
2 DX and so I have the D u right over
here so let me rewrite all of this I can
rewrite this as the integral of D u over
u is equal to G of X and this we can
rewrite as the natural log of the
absolute value of U plus C is equal to G
of X and then we can undo our u
substitution and so for you I will undo
I will substitute back the 1 minus 2 X
so I can write the natural log of the
absolute value of 1 minus 2 X is equal
to G or plus C don't want to forget that
plus C is equal to G of X and so the
next thing we want to do is well what is
our C and the easiest way to figure out
C is let's substitute 0 onto both for X
and so let's think about this a little
bit so if I put a 0 here if I put x
equals actually let me just write it
again so I'll have the natural log of if
I say X is here 0 there's gonna be the
natural log of the absolute value of 1
plus C
is equal to G of zero so what's G of
zero G of zero every one of these terms
is equal to zero
G of zero is equal to zero so is equal
to zero
well natural log of one is just 0 so 0
plus C is equal zero C is equal to zero
so there you have it I just took the
antiderivative of both sides of this
equation right over here I figured out
when I substituted 0 for X and okay my
constant here is going to be 0 and I get
that I get that this series this G of X
is equal to the natural log of the
absolute value of 1 minus 2x is equal to
the natural log of the absolute value of
1 minus 2x now if we keep this
restriction that we're in this open
interval then this is always going to be
positive and we know we don't we
wouldn't have to write the absolute
value but this this we could be safe by
writing the absolute value but there you
go using the fact above we found the
function that corresponds to this
following series and I guess you could
say the trick of it was recognizing that
that that the series of P R is a
derivative of the series down here and
so this is going to be the derivative of
the of the following series and so we
just took the antiderivative of both
sides or the indefinite integral of both
sides